[Music]
the 2017 speed chess championship brings
together 16 of the world's strongest
most super human chess players among
them you'll find none other than former
Women's World Chess Champion Grandmaster
ho Yifan the reigning US chess champion
Grandmaster Westwood so world chess
championship title challenger
grandmaster Sergey Carioca the most
feared man in bullets yes today
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura and of
course the grandmaster blitz battle
championship winner and reigning World
Chess Champion magnus halls don't miss a
single moment of the action as needed
meat chess players battle it out for the
better part of a $50,000 prize fund the
action kicks off on May 3rd
when Hikaru Nakamura takes on the first
qualified Challenger with Magnus Carlsen
playing his first match on October 5th
all the action will be brought to you on
check comm slash TV twitch.tv slash
chess or one of our numerous foreign
language portals fans can find coverage
in Russian French Portuguese Spanish and
many more go to chess calm TV to see the
full schedule of events for the 2017
speed chess championship fill out a
bracket for a chance to win big prizes
and don't miss a single moment as we
show you the world's best chess players
in this thrilling eSports event you'll
see you on chess calm
[Music]